if you're wondering what pete davidson
thinks about his girlfriend kim
kardashian's estranged husband kanye
west's new music video for easy well a
source tells e.t he is not threatened in
fact the source says he's kind of
flattered i'm just extremely happy can
you tell by my face
let me get you up to speed
on wednesday a judge granted kim's
petition to be declared legally single
amid her divorce proceedings with a 44
year old rapper and while this doesn't
mean their divorce is final it does mean
kim's considered a legally single woman
while they continue to work out a
divorce settlement yes and just a few
hours after the judge's ruling came down
yay who has been trashing kim's new bow
on social media dropped this disturbing
music video
[Music]
yeah the whole thing shows the grammy
winner kidnapping a claymation figure of
pete then burying him in the ground and
it ends with a reference to skeet yey's
go-to nickname for the 28 year old
comedian a title card reading everyone
lived happily ever after except you know
who with the name skeet crossed out now
a source tells e.t that pete is taking
it all with a grain of salt quote he
finds the fact that kanye included a
cartoon version of him in his music
video hysterical he is almost flattered
by it all because it is so ridiculous to
him you just gotta roll with it the
source adds that the saturday night live
star isn't threatened by kanye in any
way shape or form quote he's using this
to grow in more ways than one including
for himself and his relationship with
kim he is turning all of the negativity
into a positive thing i love that energy
in my life as for kim e.t soar says the
two have grown closer from all this and
the 41 year old skim's founder couldn't
be more appreciative of pete who has
made an extreme effort to put any of his
emotions aside and just be a support
system for her during this difficult
time
at the end of the day life is about
being happy quote pete has grown so much
as an adult man public figure and
partner through this process
of course kanye has made it no secret
that he wants kim back i want to pull my
family back together
that was yay in november on the drink
champs podcast and one month later he
changed the lyrics to his hit run away
[Music]
says kanye's goal is to break up kim and
pete and everyone sees that including
kim and pete
kanye will never accept that she wants
to fully separate herself from him and
that kim is on a totally different page
as for kim e.t source says she is over
it and just wants to move on it is what
it is
she knows kanye is a loose cannon and at
this point nothing surprises her
[Music]